we were working our way through the
final hour of our coverage here at the
indianapolis scouting combine 2020.
joining us now isaiah simmons of clemson
i don't know what position to say what
position should i say for isaiah simmons
um you could probably just start with
saying defense that'd probably be best
do we want to be that that that narrow
could we just say offense and defense
just football player yeah football
player works for me
what what position can't you play
defensively um i would probably say the
only thing i haven't done
would be like a nose tackle or a three
technique but uh everything else is up
in the air for me what's your favorite
position to play on defense oh man
that's a tough one
i enjoy getting interception just as
much as i do get in the sack so i don't
know if i could
um
really pick one
just because of the different feelings
that you get from from the different
positions
what feelings are you getting from the
teams you've talked to about where they
envision you what's what's the
predominant vibe
yeah so um each team you know they want
to know where i want to play or what i'm
more comfortable with
than not and then also
just like what they would see me as so
personally
like i told you i mean i don't have a
preference i'm comfortable everywhere
just because i mean i didn't have an
option i had to be comfortable if i was
going to play those positions in college
so
really that's the main thing is just
seeing how comfortable i am where how
did that develop for you because
football is so regiment and it's so much
about your position and this is who you
are how did you get to the point where
you have the flexibility and are able to
take advantage of it where you can move
around and do different things yeah i
mean a lot of film studying a lot of
repetition and practice um
just seeing them see it and seeing it on
film and then keep doing it and doing
and doing it it just becomes second
nature naturally and you know there's
there's value in being able to do a lot
of different things number one it's
easier to stay on a roster when you can
do a bunch of different things and
number two when you're on the field you
know when the offense decides to go no
huddle you're one of the chess pieces
that can get moved into a bunch of
different places to counter that so
that's got to be attractive it makes me
think of a guy like even though tyron
matthew doesn't play a lot of linebacker
i mean he can go anywhere in the
secondary and i think the more you can
do that the more valuable you are to
your defense oh absolutely i believe it
brings a huge value to each and every
team who has a guy that's able to move
around you you're coming from a program
that's got a pretty good quarterback in
uh trevor lawrence
give us an idea of of what he really
does that makes him so much better than
everyone else um a side of his athletic
ability and canon as an arm
i would say just mentally how smart he
is that's what really makes him such a
great quarterback is
he's smart and he's really poised
great patience in the pocket and he also
knows when to pull it down and run and i
told him uh just this past season
i said you're a dual threat now you
didn't open up a run game so um
you know that's just made him even more
better of a quarterback how frustrating
is it when he takes off running in
practice and you can't go hit him i mean
coach sweeney he really emphasizes not
to touch the quarterbacks so especially
him but um
you know it it's frustrating at times
but you know you just run next to him
and say what you know guys chat back and
forth but how many times you pick them
off in practice a couple of times i i
don't know i can't count what do you
what do you say what do you say when you
do that um
well we have a big thing on telling our
quarterbacks not to throw checkdowns in
practice because a lot of times we'll be
there and they'll just throw a check
down because they don't want to throw an
interception but um
you know every time i throw every time
he throws me interception i throw the
ball back to him just so he has a good
feeling so he can experience it exactly
exactly um
how old were you when you knew that you
were going to be able to play at a high
level what happened what was the moment
where you're like man i can do this i
probably saved my first offer so i got
my first offer my sophomore year
of high school and
after that one offer came then it's kind
of like a domino effect then more
schools and more schools and more
schools start to come so
going into my junior year
that's when i really found out that i
was going to be able to play at a high
level
what did it do if anything to your
mindset to your confidence when you
started to realize maybe you know i can
do this did you feel yourself carrying
yourself any differently no i mean i
think the only thing it did was make me
work even harder because it made me want
to be the best at the highest level
that you know that it's there that it's
real yeah but you got to work together i
just when i found out that it was
obtainable for me then it made me want
to do nothing but work harder let's take
a quick look olathe north yeah
highlights of isaiah simmons and uh you
know usually
usually the guy stands oh my god wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
oh you is that you yeah
so you play low receiver yeah yeah you
don't look that big i don't mean that as
an insult that guy's a giant yeah just
everybody else is really small how tall
are you oh six four wow that's six four
that's randy moss saw zach you can hit
two yeah uh you could play some offense
you should not just call yourself
defense yeah you know in high school i
consider myself a receiver then then a
safety what are you gonna run the 40 in
fast so i have to say fast well how fast
i don't i don't want to throw any
numbers out there but it's fast
um i would say fast as is in the fourth
reason unders oh man oh seriously uh
you you could you could uh you could uh
get to do a little offense and
defensively nfl i got a feeling we're
going to see we're going to see isaiah
simmons catching some past how fast do
you run down the hill at clemson out to
the stage not fast not fast you enjoy it
soak it up right yeah i mean but also
we've seen a lot of videos of people
falling at the bottom because it's very
it's really steep so
um i wanted to make sure i went through
a career without falling hey we gotta
let you go we already held you over a
minute for your time at the podium so
isaiah simmons he'll be at the podium in
a minute and we appreciate some of your
time in the nfl soon thanks buddy thank
you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports